de Marioupol à feu et à flammes
après des bombardements russes.t
d'une bombe tombée non loin
du bâtiment. Les survivants qui
peuvent encore marcher fuient
l'enfer.esesesesesesesesesesese;
une autre femme, le visage
ensanglanté, quitte la matérnité
en vie, mais sous le choc.
Ce député ukrainien
confirme l'a a a a a a a a a a n
de la part de la Russie.
Des locaux de la matérnité,
il ne des murs arrachés,
des incubateurs projetés
par le souffle des missiles.
Le port stratégique de Marioupol
(explosion) U U U U Un blocus qt
plus de 1000 morts, selon
les autorités de la ville.ururue
Ukraine Crisis Media Center
- On a vu aussi des images
de tombes de masse, en fait.
Autant il y a des molslslslslslt
pour enterrer les gens dans
cette ville assiégée où tout
manque : l'électricité, l'eau,
la nourriturpppppppppppppppppppt
d'une fillette de 6 ans
de déshydratation.FRFRFRFRFRFRÇt
d'études internationales, UQAM
- Les civils ont le droit de
quitter les lieux d'hostilités.
recevoir de l'aide humanitaire.
Donc assiéger, couper de leur
approvisionnement, attaquer
les civils, tout ça, c'est
évidemment desonononononononono.
Mais on est visiblement face
à une armée, il y a un président
qui outrepasse systématiquem
les conventions de Genève
- L'attaque sur l'hôpital
pédiatrique de Marioupol,
le président Zelensky l'a
Hier encore, il affirmait
qu'il restait ouvert
au dialogue avec les Russes,
mais qu'il n'est pas prêt de
revient au peuple ukrainien,
qui l'a élu. Il s'mememememememe
dit ouvert à un compromis
sur le statut des territoires
En attendant, la mince lueur
d'espoir de prochains
continuent de subir les bombes
et de se ter a a a a a a abris.
- Je pense que plus l'armée
ukrainienne résiste, plus
et plus ils sont en colère;
je veux dire les Russes,
plus ils sont
- Une colère qui repartira
de plus belle à l'aube d'une
quinzième K K K K K K K K K K K,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.